for some perspective we turned to
Douglas al Avant he's senior fellow at
the New America Foundation and a former
National Security Council director he's
in our Washington bureau Doug good
morning
morning I think you were on the National
Security Council in both the Bush and
Obama administrations what do you think
went into this decision last night
exactly to launch it strike against
Syria well the point of the the NSC is
to make complicated issues and you know
take complicated issues turn them into
relatively simple policies so this
probably came down to really two very
simple questions one do we believe that
the Assad regime did conduct these
attacks which it appears we clearly do
and then to if so what do you do and it
appeared what we were trying to do here
is steer between two things we did not
want we did not want the strikes to be
weak enough that they did not change the
regime's calculus but on the other hand
we did not want them to be heavy enough
that they crossed Russian and perhaps
even Iranian red lines Doug we heard
defense secretary mattis say last night
that there were no additional attacks
planned at this time do you think that
last night's strikes were strong enough
deterrent I think the only answer that
is we will see I think objectively
speaking what we're trying to do is
change the regime's calculus make it so
that while you may get some military
gain from these chemical strikes what we
will do to you in return makes that
objectively not worth it that that the
punishment that will be inflicted
outweighs any gain that you get from
those attacks but we'll see if that kind
of rational calculus appeals to the
Assad regime as David Martin mentioned
this is the second time the Trump
administration has launched attacks
against Syria responding to chemical
weapons how does this attack differ from
the last one which was in April of 2017
well it's it's I think it differs in two
ways it's it was a little bit bigger
we're told that they use twice as many
munitions this time and it was focused
very specifically on the chemical
infrastructure but I think some of us
were surprised to find still existed but
weapons research facilities storage
facilities very specifically focused on
that infrastructure you know that last
attack last year 59 Tomahawk missiles
placed on to one airbase there 24 hours
later their airbase was up and running
what do you think the Russian response
will be to this well that is the big
question and and all the briefings last
night we're very careful to point out
that this was not about engaging the
Russians that measures were taken to
avoid Russian casualties but I think the
only answer to that is we will see if
this crosses their red lines and whether
they respond whether in Syria and in
kind or in some other asymmetric kind of
way all of them thank you so much for
joining us Doug pleasure arena